Welcome, everyone, to our master class in data storytelling.
We're very excited with the panel that will be presented and presenting in a few minutes.
I will moderate the panel.
My name is Haya Al Nasser and I work for the communications directorate at the Census Bureau,
but I'm also the editor of America Counts, Stories Behind the Numbers, which is one of
the more recent and successful product launches at the Census Bureau that deals with data
storytelling all the way.
So it was one of our more creative efforts of the past few years.
So just to give you a little bit of background, I am a former journalist.
I spent almost 20 years as the lead census and demographics reporter at USA Today and
worked for Al Jazeera America after that.
Once I left journalism and joined the Census Bureau, my mission was clear.
It was to basically apply my journalistic experience to helping the Census Bureau communicate
its data products in a more relatable way and to a broader audience.
So in the fall of 2017, we launched a new content platform called America Counts.
And I'm going to share my screen so I can show you the website and let me know if you
can see it.
It looks, can you see it?
I assume you can see it.
So here's the landing page.
Not yet.
Not yet?
Please try again.
Okay.
You cannot share, it tells me.
Why would that be?
Let me see if this is going to work.
Somebody can make you a co-host and then you can share.
There we go.
Now we can see.
We can see it now.
Now you're muted.
Muted, Haya.
Now it's, it's very strange.
It won't let me unmute.
So now let's hope it's still, now it's, is it going to be sharing?
Yes, it's still sharing.
Okay.
So this is our website.
So as you can see, we're, I've applied the news site model to the America Counts page.
The top story is the most recent story we've published.
And then at the bottom, you'll see in chronological descending order, all the other stories.
So I just want to point out that when you look at all this content, well, we publish
about two to three stories a week on average.
When you look at all this, all of these stories began as probably a data file or an Excel
spreadsheet, but we are telling stories through all the various components.
The image tells a story, the headline tells a story, the teaser text tells a story.
I'll open one of the pages just to give you an idea of some of the other components that
we think are key in data storytelling.
So here you have, we add the subhead, which again is another piece of the story.
Please note that we are very conscious of keeping the writing clear and direct, short
paragraphs.
As you all know, most folks who read things online tend to be scrollers and scanners.
If you have all this in one great text, they'll skip a lot of stuff in between.
We also know that more and more people are reading things on their smartphones.
If you put these two paragraphs together, it would probably fill up the screen, which
makes it pretty unreadable.
Other components are pullout, text, maps, section breaks, which are really important
in organizing the story and making it more accessible to the readers, graphics, and so
on.
Again, I'm going to tell you really quickly, show you another data storytelling tool that
we've used.
Let's see if this loads.
Okay.
This is a story that we ran last spring, which was extremely popular.
The story basically highlights interactive data visualization, which I will show you
in a second.
So again, strong headlines that tell the story, subhead that tells a story, all of this.
The bullet points, all this.
And then this takes you to the actual interactive data visualization, which was extremely popular.
This allows you to compare teachers' pay with all other occupation.
As you can see, you can drop the menu and pick any other occupation and compare what
teachers are getting paid by educational level.
And the interactive continues with more very appealing visuals.
So I just wanted to give you a quick intro to some of the work that we are doing at the
Census Bureau in the area of data storytelling.
And I'm happy to report that it has been quite successful.
We are nearing 12 million page visits since we launched in the fall of 2017.
And we're growing at a faster rate than we added just 4 million of those visits, I believe
just in the past year.
So I'll just close with that and I'll make sure I put a link and my contact info in the
chat.
But let me go ahead and introduce our next speaker.
And I assume I'm no longer sharing, right?
So good.
I can still see your screen.
Some people don't see the screen, so perhaps change the view of your window when you click
on the right-hand side, it says gallery side-by-side speaker.
So for those that can't see, perhaps try to toggle your options.
And now you're going to be seeing effective ways to use data.
Okay.
Then it's fine.
Then we're good.
So I'm going to go ahead and introduce our first speaker.
Brent Dykes is the founder and chief data storyteller at Analytics Hero LLC.
He's also the author of Effective Data Storytelling, How to Drive Change with Data, Narrative, and
Visuals.
Brent has nearly two decades of enterprise analytics experience at Omniture, Adobe, Domo,
and Blast Analytics.
His passion for data storytelling comes from consulting with many industry leaders, including
Ikea, Nike, Microsoft, Sony, and Comcast.
He's a regular Forbes contributor and has written more than 45 articles on different
data-related topics.
He's a popular speaker at conferences such as Strata, Web Summit, Shop.org, Ad Tech,
PopCon, Rise, Crunch, and Adobe Summit, and of course today, the Top Summit.
So Brent, take it away.
Thank you, Hannah.
I'm excited here to talk about effective ways to use data stories or data powerful data
stories.
So one of the things we may question whether we need more data, right?
I think we're all have a lot of data that we're using today and in sharing that with
other people, it can be overwhelming.
But what everybody's really thirsty for, what they're really seeking are insights.
And this is something that we really need to focus on.
And I believe that if we look at an insight, it really needs to be at the core of every
good data story or powerful data story.
We need an insight, not just more data or more observations, but actually insights.
Now when I was writing my book, I had some of my book reviewers when they're reading
draft copies of my book, effective data storytelling, they mentioned, oh, well, you're using the
word insight a lot, but you haven't really defined what it is.
And so I was like, oh, yeah, sure.
That's a great idea. I'll add that to the first chapter.
And then when I went in and tried to decide, well, what is an insight, I realized that
maybe I used that that term really loosely and didn't really have a good idea of what
it really meant. And so I turned to the dictionaries, started looking at the dictionary,
seeing what they kind of represented.
And it didn't really resonate with me until somebody pointed me to this definition by
Gary Klein, who's a psychologist and author.
And he said that an insight is an unexpected shift in the way we understand things.
Now, this is really important because I think what happens a lot of the time is we have
an observation in the data, we find something interesting, maybe an interesting trend or
anomaly or something like that, and we call that an insight.
But really, that's not an insight.
So let me give you an example here.
So maybe we're looking at some data here and we see high speed Internet access grew by
23 percent in our state last year.
And that that may be surprising or unexpected, but really, that's just what it doesn't
really get into the why. What what drove that?
And so if we dig in a little bit further, we might discover something interesting,
something that shifts our understanding.
In this case, the 80 percent of this increase came from a local government initiative to
expand access for low income families.
And so with that insight, we have something now that we can do something with.
Now, when we analyze the data, we go through it, we find something interesting, we find
an insight and the numbers are so clear to us, they're so compelling.
And we say that the numbers speak for themselves.
And so we share that out with other people.
And what happens, though, is that the numbers don't speak for themselves.
What happens is they really do need a data storyteller.
They need a narrator, need somebody to really explain what those insights mean
and help people to understand them.
So when I look at data storytelling, there are really three key elements that I focus
on, probably no surprise, because probably before this presentation would have said,
oh, yeah, data, narrative and visuals.
But I think the power of data storytelling really comes in when we look at the
intersections of these bubbles.
Now, the first thing is I could do some analysis, I could find an insight and I could
share a spreadsheet with you.
And you could look at that same spreadsheet and say, I don't understand what you're
sharing with me, Brian, I don't see any insight here.
Or maybe you see a different insight or maybe you misinterpret the insight that I'm
sharing. And so we we don't do that.
What we do is we combine the narrative with the data to help make sure that the
information is clear, that it's concrete and that we're explaining the numbers to the
audience so they can really understand it and come away with the same insight that we
get. Another thing we do is we use visuals because sometimes if we look at that table
of data, there's a good chance that we're not going to see the anomalies, we're not
going to see the patterns or trends in the numbers.
And it's only when the numbers are visualized that we can actually enlighten the
audience to these key findings that we have in our data.
And the last intersection here that I want to focus on is between the visuals and the
narrative. Now, one of the things we do as human beings is we love to hear stories,
they engage us at a very deep level and especially the visual storytelling.
We may have been up binge watching our favorite show on Netflix or Amazon Prime.
So the interesting thing is when we bring the right data, we combine it with the right
narrative and the right visuals, all of a sudden we have something that's very powerful,
that can change the way people view the world, can change how they behave and what
actions they take. So this is very powerful.
Now, the interesting thing that you might be surprised to hear from a data guy is that
stories beat statistics.
You know, this is this is very interesting.
I like this quote by Robert McKee, who he trains a lot of the script writers in
Hollywood. And he said that storytelling is one of the most powerful ways to put ideas
in the world today. And the same goes for insights.
Now, let's look at the differences between stories and statistics.
There's two ways that stories beat statistics.
And these both come from a great book written by Chip and Dan Heath, if you're familiar
with it, Made to Stick. It's on communication.
And in that book, Chip Heath, who is a professor at Stanford University, shares how
stories are more memorable. And he shares an example of an activity that he does with
an undergrad class of communication students, where he gives them a bunch of data on a
particular topic and asks them to incorporate the data or statistics into their
presentations. And they create these short presentations.
On average, the students are using about two and a half statistics in these
presentations. And the other interesting side note is one in ten of these students
will actually include an anecdote, a short anecdote in their presentations.
So they go through this exercise, they divide up into groups, they present to each
other, they rate each other and give feedback.
And they think the activity is over.
But about 10 minutes later, the professor comes back to them and says, OK, how many
of these statistics do you actually remember?
And the interesting thing that only about five percent of them could remember any
statistics, but 63 percent of them could remember the stories.
And so our human brains, when we try to make sense of the world around us, we're
trying to put things into stories or trying to make sense of this world.
And so stories make our information more memorable.
The next thing is, is that stories are more persuasive.
And so the example in the book that they share is a study from Carnegie Mellon
University where students were asked to take a technology survey.
And at the end of that survey, they were given five one dollar bills.
And then they were asked if they'd like to donate some of that money to a local
charity. And this charity was Save the Children.
And so they gave them two brochures on this charity and one version of this
brochure talked about all of the suffering of children in Africa and how,
you know, due to illness or war or famine and shared lots of data and statistics
on the number of children that are being impacted.
So that was one version. The other version didn't include any data.
It basically just talked about the story of Rukia, a seven year old girl from
Bali and talked about the suffering of her family and what they went through.
And when they looked at the average donations for both versions, they found
that the story version generated a much higher average donation than the
statistics did. So for these two reasons, it's really important that we take our
data and let's work it weave it into stories.
I like to say that we hear statistics, but we feel stories.
And so when neuroscientists look at our brains, we hear facts being shared with
us. There's a couple of regions of our brain that light up and they're strictly
associated with processing language.
However, when somebody hears a story or sharing a story and they they look at the
brain, they see other regions of the brain light up.
And that's because they're not only are they experienced or hearing what the
people are saying, they're also experiencing it as well.
So it's a much more deeper connection when you're telling a story as opposed to
just sharing facts.
Another thing that's interesting about sharing facts is that how we receive them,
right? When we have information that's shared with us that maybe conflicts with
our worldview, we're going to go into defensive mode.
Our shields are going to come up and we're going to come much more critical and
skeptical of this information.
However, when we are approached with a story, all of a sudden, our shields come
down. We drop that analytical guard.
We're not likely not as likely to nitpick on the details.
We want to see where the story goes.
And so this opens an opportunity for us to convey our information in a way that's
going to resonate with people.
I like to look at it this way.
We have all this evidence that we have.
We have the data, which really speaks to the logical side.
But a lot of the time, decisions are being made by emotion.
And the story is what enables us to connect with that emotion that that goes into a
lot of decision making.
So today, I want to give you three quick tips on how to turn your information into
powerful data stories.
The first one, and I think this is important, is that we need to match the narrative to
the audience, right?
So here's the same story.
This is the story of Robin Hood told multiple different ways.
And if I were holding a birthday party for six year olds, I probably couldn't use the
four on the right without getting in trouble with the parents.
The one on the left, maybe the kids would get bored.
And so really, I need to focus on that Disney one.
Now, if it was a different audience, maybe maybe it's 16 year olds or 30 year olds, I'm
going to choose a different one.
And so it's really important that when we look at our data story, we need to determine
who the right audience is for our story, or we mean to look at, you know, adjusting our
data story to the audience that we're sharing it with.
The second tip is how do we apply?
Can we apply a narrative structure to our findings?
So when I was researching for my book, I found I was looking at different models and I came
across Gustav Freytag, who was a German playwright, who he studied, like Shakespearean
plays and Greek tragedies.
And he defined, he identified that they all had a story arc.
And I've taken that story arc and I've applied it to data storytelling.
We can take the same approach, just like a story that sets the scene for the for the
characters and the story that they're about to tell.
We can do the same thing with our data storytelling.
You want to establish what are the expected trends that we typically see, you know, giving
background on what is this data that we're looking at.
And then we have a hook.
And the hook is really where there's something that that's unusual and observation.
Something's changed.
Maybe a metric went up sharply or down significantly, and that caught our attention and
that would capture the the attention of the audience as well.
And then from there, we dig into, well, why did that occur?
What's going on?
What caused that?
And so we have rising insights that start to build up to our aha moment, which is our
main insight that we're sharing, our major finding, our central insight that we want
the audience to remember.
Now, we're not done at that point because we want the audience to do something.
And that's where, you know, we're recommending either a solution or we're recommending
And that's where, you know, we're recommending either a solution or we're showing different
options and discussing the next steps.
And through this process, the audience is learning more about this topic and hopefully
they're putting they're being put into a position to act on it and make decisions.
Now, how do we do this?
I'll give you an example here from a real world example.
And this was based on a retailer that had its analytics team, and they were looking
at their customer data, the transactions.
And so the the analytics team was expecting to see something like this, you know, a normal
standard distribution of their orders by size.
And what they found was this.
There was this second peak that surprised them.
They weren't expecting that.
That was unexpected.
And again, that's not an insight by itself until they dig into it to find out what was
causing the second peak.
When they did, they discovered that there was a segment of customers that were coming
into their physical stores from outside the country.
This retailer only had a presence in the United States and didn't have any stores outside
of the United States.
And international buyers were coming into their physical stores, making large bulk
purchases and taking it back to their home countries to sell in their own stores.
And then from there, they were able to make recommendations about maybe how they expand
into these countries, how maybe they partner with some of these resellers.
And what you're seeing here is the taking those findings of an analysis and turning
it into a data story that can be shared, that's persuasive and memorable and engaging.
The next tip that we have is obviously we have a lot of data and we want to use the
visuals to amplify our messages.
So in this case here, we're looking at COVID testing 2021, 2020 for various regions.
And this chart is good.
I mean, it's definitely sharing the data.
You know, obviously we can look at it and see the insights.
Now, the question is, maybe there's a better chart out there.
Often what I recommend is iterating until you find a chart that really amplifies your
message.
In this case, maybe we want to go with a different chart.
This is a slope graph chart.
And in this case here, the angle of the slopes indicate, you know, if something growing or
has increased significantly, you're going to see a sharper slope there than maybe the
ones that are just wasn't much change.
You know, you're not going to see as sharp an angle, pretty flat or decreasing.
And so in this case here, maybe this chart is more effective than the one on the left.
Another thing we can do is we can use color to really bring out our key points, right?
So in this case here, we want to focus the audience's attention on region B, where we
had this massive increase in COVID tests that grew 18% far and above any other region.
And then finally, another thing that we can do is we can take that generic descriptive
title and we can turn it into something where we have an explanatory headline or title
that's really going to draw the attention of the audience to the key point that we're
trying to make about region B.
And so that ends my, I want to conclude my presentation with this quote from Stephen
Few, you know, that the numbers have an important story to tell and they rely on you to
give them a clear and convincing voice.
And if you'd like to learn more about my philosophies on data storytelling, please check
out my book, Effective Data Storytelling.
Thank you, Brent.
That was fantastic.
Really appreciate it.
I'm going to introduce our next speaker, who's a former colleague of mine, by the
way.
Lam Thuy Vo is a journalist who marries data analysis with underground reporting to
examine how systems and policies affect individuals.
She's currently a Soros Justice Fellow and AI Accountability Fellow for the Pulitzer
Center and a data journalist and residence at the Craig Newmark Graduate School of
Journalism.
She has worked with Documented, ProPublica, The Guardian, The New York Times, and ESPN
as an independent reporter.
Previously, she was a journalist at BuzzFeed News, The Wall Street Journal, Al Jazeera
America, and NPR's Planet Money.
Lam?
Hi, everyone.
My name is Lam, and I'm very excited to see who is in the house.
I've been seeing some of the bios I've been reading.
I love how many folks I hear from Puerto Rico.
I think there are a lot of stories that you can do in Puerto Rico using Census data, but
I am particularly excited to nerd out about data when it comes to the Census Bureau
because I use it so much.
And one of the things I will start doing is I have already put into the Slack site, into
the chat, the links to my slides.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to share my, I think, desktop, which you will
see is catastrophically overly, I have too many links and everything, but if there's
one thing that you will take away from today, I would like for you to take a screenshot
right now, yes, of my desktop, but you'll also see the link here.
All you need to get in touch with me, to look at the things that are on these slides, are
on that link, right?
So go for that.
You can also find me on Twitter and you'll find that afterwards as well.
So I am so excited to talk about Census data today because I am a nerd.
I love the American Community Survey and other surveys that the Census Bureau puts out.
This is me in, I think, 2018 filling out an American Community Survey with so much pride.
This is why I'm here.
I cannot tell you that I even texted my partner as soon as I was told to speak to me.
I even texted my partner as soon as I was told to speak to the Census Bureau, for the
Census Bureau, and I can attest to you that this data is extremely important.
So to give you a quick understanding of who I am, maybe it helps you to understand the
context through which I'm talking to you about today.
I used to be a videographer for the Wall Street Journal.
I was a data vis and video person for NPR.
I was an interactive editor for Al Jazeera America.
In all of those jobs as a journalist with multiple media, Census data at some point
played a role in how I viewed the stories I was doing.
Then I became a BuzzFeed reporter.
The story we're going to talk about today is from BuzzFeed where I looked into basically
any kinds of stories that were du jour at that point in time, identifying news trends
and then figuring out ways to tell those stories in multiple platforms and using different
types of data.
And now I'm a data journalist in residence at CUNY where I teach these things.
I've been teaching data journalism for a good decade.
So if you have any questions in that small corner, you can see my email address.
I tell my students I come with a lifetime guarantee, which is probably bad for my social
life, but most people don't seem to email me, so you have that.
And you can also find me on Twitter under the handle Alam Tuivo.
So with all of that out of the way, I want to talk to you about a sample story today.
And I want to walk you through how you can use census data in a way that might not seem
as intuitive.
In my capacity as a reporter, I used to be a general assignment reporter, but in my capacity
as a reporter, I at that point in time was doing a lot of social media data listening.
And what I found in 2018, we're going to walk through a story today that addresses the
idea of that was formulated when people started looking into viral incidences around
white folks in a neighborhood calling the cops and black and brown folks for doing
seemingly very normal things.
If anyone of you remembers in 2018, there were several incidents that went viral,
including one about Barbecue Becky, a woman who called the cops on her black neighbors
who were having a barbecue at the park saying that they weren't using a permit to do so.
There was a woman called Permit Patty.
If you remember them, this person was calling the cops on a, I think it was a Latino child
who was selling water without a permit.
And these incidents kept on going viral at that point in time.
And one of the things that my editor and I wanted to do at that point in time in 2018
was to better understand the hypothesis that all of these folks were formulating
by making these stories go viral.
So with this said, the hypothesis, it seemed to be looking at the conversation around
these topics, looking at this particular, the particular stories around it was that
white folks who move into gentrifying neighborhoods might be calling the cops on their black
and brown neighbors more often, which leads to over-policing.
And this was an interesting story to tackle.
It was A, very controversial.
It was B, also something that was kind of hard to prove.
And so one of the things that we wanted to do, my editor and I, was to come up with better
ideas of understanding how we can tackle this statistically so that we can go from having
anecdotal viral conversations about a topic to one that is more informed by hypothesis
building, data analysis, and then figuring out whether this was actually something that
was, that we could prove statistically to some degree.
And one of the reasons why I'm fascinated by this is that it taps into a power dynamic
that is very much something that we have observed ever since then in many gentrifying
neighborhoods where sometimes more affluent new residents seem to have a disproportionate
amount of power over long-term residents who in the end get displaced from their neighborhoods.
So with this said, one of the things that we wanted to do was to find a trend for this
hypothesis.
What's interesting is that what we needed to figure out was to find two to three different
measurements based on that hypothesis, right?
If the hypothesis is, as I remind you, if more white folks move into, who are more affluent
move into gentrifying neighborhoods, there will be more calls to the cops, which may
lead to over-policing.
And one of the things that we needed to measure with that was gentrification, demographic
changes, and then also calls to the police.
And the three data sources that we used for that were 311 calls.
So 311 calls are the types of quality of life complaints that go to a city's hotline.
And then from that hotline, the city can connect you to different people.
This data is open.
This data is out there.
I think at that point in time, we were looking at 17 million rows of data, and we were able
to work with analyses that other folks had done before to better understand what of this
data set would constitute calling the cops on your neighbors.
The second thing that we needed to do was to find a trend for this hypothesis.
And this is where ACS, or American Community Survey, data came in really strong.
We used census data to look into census tracts all over New York City that went from being
some of the poorest, so in the bottom 40th percentile, if that makes any sense to you,
to one of the more affluent census tracts as compared to the region.
We also looked at census tracts that went from being the poorest, so in the bottom 40th
as compared to the region.
We also looked at that from a stance of median home value and median income, as well as
understanding whether there may be more folks, and this was an analysis done by Columbia
and then later by another magazine, if there may have also been an increase of people who
were 25 and older and had a bachelor's degree.
All of those tests, so to speak, were academic tests that someone did to figure out
whether a census tract, which is a small geographic location, the smallest sort of like
one of the smallest divisions of a geographic area had gentrified, had gone from not so
affluent to more affluent.
That was one analysis we did.
We looked into whether it was correlated to the calls to cops about noise and about other
things that you found bothersome about your neighbors.
And then we also looked into demographic changes.
Now, this is a very convoluted and very boring way of saying the hypothesis that many people
on the Internet were formulating seemed to statistically check out.
This graphic shows you that.
And for that, we were able to use ACS data to do a larger statistical study to see whether
there is a correlation between gentrification and calling the cops on your neighbors.
And what we also saw, thanks to the census data, was that in the neighborhoods where
there was a gentrified, where there was a higher rate per capita of calling the cops,
we also saw demographic changes.
This is a sort of convoluted chart that kind of makes that point of showing that in gentrifying
neighborhoods where the calls were higher per capita to cops about noise complaints
and other complaints about your neighbors, there were also major demographic changes.
You could see that there were demographic changes in terms of more white folks moving
in and fewer Black folks living in that neighborhood as a percentage of the entire neighborhood.
So I've now explained to you how we went from looking at viral incidents to doing
statistical analyses with the ACS to them being like, oh, the hypothesis that all of
these folks on the Internet were kind of like speaking about, that seems to check out.
And trust me, I've done enough to try and disprove my hypothesis, to try and disprove
this hypothesis.
This is a very controversial subject, so I wanted to make sure that it was extra right.
And we were able to prove that.
And what you can see is also that in a visual sense, one of the ways in which we showed
this map is the tracks that are outlined, our census tracks that gentrified.
The error up meant that the white population as a percentage of that neighborhood went
up.
And the darker the shade of each census track, the higher the calls per capita were to complain
about noise, to complain about, quote unquote, illegal usage of an apartment.
So this very clearly shows certain trends.
But I can tell you all these things and I can make you feel like this is really important.
But one of the things that's really important as well is to kind of bring that data and
bring these findings down to a more visceral understanding of the subject.
And so what we did for that story as well was to look into one block.
What are interesting outliers, or not outliers, what are extreme versions or good emblematic
examples of how this may manifest itself?
And we found one block in Harlem, which was predominantly Dominican, where there were
3,000 noise complaints over the course of three years.
And as you can see here in this little data visualization, you can see that one address
had 1,118 noise complaints lobbed against it between 2015 and 2017.
And this kind of brings it down to a block level.
Imagine living in a block and there were 3,000 noise complaints.
One of those days had 100 noise complaints.
What does this say about the ways in which we handle conflict in those areas?
And so I was able to go from showing the trend, understanding sort of like whether
figuring out a way of looking into that hypothesis of discrimination that might be
happening in gentrifying neighborhoods, to finding a hot spot.
And the main part that it comes down to as well to make you understand the story better,
because I can tell you all the statistics around it, is we wanted to find a person.
And we found this young man.
He's 105 years old.
He used to live on that very street.
And he did tell us, and I think we interviewed about 40 people to get to that point.
He did tell us that he, after 30, I think it was four decades of living in that block,
once the noise complaints kept on going up, he had to stop living the way he used to live
his life, playing dominoes outside and I guess having chit chat outside on the streets.
So one of the things that we needed to do was to go from the larger findings of the
data down to what that feels like on the ground to real human beings.
And with that said, I think once we had explored that, we also wanted to find a better
understanding of the why behind the data.
And I think that is one of the main parts that sometimes is more difficult to get to.
And that takes a lot more research with experts who have either worked with populations
there, experts who live on that block, people who are experts in their lived experience,
as well as experts who work on an academic level on that.
And we were able to find the why behind that data by talking to several folks.
So this is a quote from a person who studies gentrification.
He mentioned that when you live in a neighborhood where you feel comfortable knocking
on your neighbor's door, then you would do that.
So what he means by that is that a lot of people felt very uncomfortable
due to racial issues, due to being new and having longer established folks.
Whatever the reason was, they didn't feel comfortable talking to their neighbors
about the noise complaints, about the noise outside.
And so instead mediated the conflict through a third party.
Right.
That was one of the whys.
And then we also spoke to several people who did call the cops on that block on their
neighbors.
And one of them said there's this tendency among new residents of people of not
addressing problems directly.
He said he had called 311 a few times to deal with his downstairs neighbor who was
playing loud rap music.
He also said he didn't feel safe approaching his neighbor to ask for the music to be
turned down.
He said this used to be a bad neighborhood, even though this stands in stark contrast
with crime rates in that neighborhood as well.
And so I think one of the things that's hopefully clear through this story is that
some of the things that you might be seeing, the hypothesis that you might be
building around something can be really answered through very clear analyses, almost
like a scientific way of using census data to tell those kinds of stories.
Thank you, Lam.
That was a wonderful presentation.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you again.
And please, before we go to the next speaker, let me remind everyone if you have any
questions, you can drop them in the chat and we'll try to get to them at the end of
the presentations.
So let's go to our third speaker, who is Shannon Arvizu, who is a sociologist and
senior advisor in the Office of the Chief Data Officer at the Department of
Commerce.
She combines her expertise in organizational change management, social science
and systems thinking to support evidence-based policymaking efforts.
In her role within the Department of Commerce, she leads efforts to improve the
use of data for federal programs aimed at increasing equitable outcomes and
opportunities for communities across the country.
She also leads two equitable data communities of practice, one for data
practitioners within the DOC and one for practitioners within a larger federal
landscape aimed at building capacity for more rigorous government program
design.
In addition, Dr. Arvizu is the founder of Epic Teams, a leading consultancy in the
field of agile organizational performance.
Shannon?
All right.
Thank you so much.
And thank you, Lam, for that very inspiring example of data journalism in
action.
So, I want to share with you today the power of data storytelling to solve
public problems better.
And I hope that after this presentation, you are all inspired to be equitable
data practitioners.
And I want to first start with a personal story of how pandemic data led to my
tour of duty in public service.
So, with that, I will share my next slide.
I'm a sociologist, and I've always been very passionate and interested about how
social change occurs.
How do our institutions evolve to better meet the needs of the common good?
And we know that all social change happens through organizations.
Organizations are the medium through which ideas and resources and data turn
into products and services and policies.
And I spent the last 10 years working inside mission-driven organizations to
help them do that transformational work.
And in particular, I helped them develop systems to do three things better.
How to build the right things in the right way and at the right speed for the
people that they serve.
And I built a pretty successful practice, worked my way up to Fortune 500
companies, helped them surpass their revenue goals and help some tech
companies achieve billion-dollar exits.
And then the pandemic hit.
And all of a sudden, we were all inside during lockdown looking at
dashboards every day.
And I found it super fascinating as a sociologist to see that Americans
across the country were governing their daily lives by data, looking at
hospitalization rates and infection rates and death rates.
And it really got me thinking, wow, okay, where is all the other data about
where all other parts of our society are doing?
And it was really interesting to also look at the intersection between COVID
data and sociodemographic data.
And we saw, for example, that there were pretty wide disparities when it
came to health outcomes.
We know that Black and Latino and Asian communities were disproportionately
impacted, mostly because they were more likely to be living in homes where
there was a higher density and were more likely to live in jobs that were
not remote.
We also know that there were wide disparities in economic impacts.
Here's a line of folks in line for a food bank in Brooklyn.
And we know that those that were in low-paying jobs, again, were
disproportionately impacted by the pandemic.
And low-paying jobs account for 30% of all American jobs.
And we know that Black and Latino women in particular are more likely to be
in those lower-paying jobs.
And lower-paying jobs accounted for 56% of all jobs that were lost during
that time.
We also saw that there were disparities in terms of educational outcomes.
We know that those in predominantly Black and Indigenous communities
already experienced disparities when it came to access to books and high
student-to-teacher ratio.
And they were also less likely to have access to computers and the internet,
which had a greater impact than just on their educational outcomes.
It also affected a lot of other outcomes.
I have this quote here from the Harvard Graduate School Education
Dean Bridget Long.
And she says, you think about schools and academics, but a child's school
is social and emotional support.
It's safety.
It's a food system.
It's health care.
It's all of those things that those students missed out on during that
time.
And unfortunately, we also saw disparities when it came to access to
basic necessities like clean, running water in your home.
We know that those in Navajo country, for example, about 30% didn't have
access to clean, running water in their homes.
And that also proved to be a challenge in a time when frequent hand
washing was a way to stay healthy.
So all of those disparities existed before the pandemic.
And this pandemic data really brought to light the differences that
Americans experience based on where they live and where they come from.
And those have real impacts for the type of life that you lead and also
how long of a life that you lead.
And so this became my passion during the pandemic.
I became really interested in understanding how might our government
institutions better deliver the right things in the right way and at the
right speed for the communities who need it most.
And when I say government, I want to introduce a definition of citizens
working together to solve shared problems.
And this to me really is the definition of being an American.
And when I had the opportunity to be of service to our chief data officer
team at the Department of Commerce, I jumped at it because I thought
there's no better way for me to use my talents and skills to be able to
help contribute to furthering of this mission.
And what I've uncovered in my time so far is that there are millions of
civil servants that are working to fulfill this core purpose of our
government, which is to equip every American with a fair shot to build
their best life possible for themselves and for their families.
And our government has made some historic investments in the last couple
years to address those disparities, including the American Rescue Plan,
which provided things like stimulus checks and emergency rental assistance
and support to schools in order to strengthen the safety net when it was
most weak.
We also know that there was a second historic investment called the
Infrastructure Bill, which made investments in things like improved
water quality for those in Navajo country, for example, and bringing
broadband to rural communities so they can access education and
employment opportunities.
So with all of this, we ask ourselves, how do we know whether we are
actually moving the needle to address those disparities?
And there's a movement underway in the federal government, which I'll call
the Equitable Data Movement, and this is a movement spearheaded by
White House Chief Data Scientist Denise Ross and others that really
builds on the work of the Evidence Act, which was passed in 2019 nearly
unanimously by those in Congress, to build an evidence-based policy
culture.
And so to drill a little bit deeper into this notion of equitable data,
we have this definition, which is data which enables rigorous
assessment of the extent to which government programs and policies
yield consistently fair, just, and impartial treatment of all
individuals.
And the reason why this is so important is because we need to focus
on opportunities for targeted actions to result in improved outcomes
for underserved communities.
And I want to share with you an example.
Since I'm using the term equity, oftentimes people are curious about
what's the difference between equality and equity.
And so if you take a rental assistance program, from an equality
perspective, every county receives an equal amount of rental assistance
funds, whereas from an equity perspective, counties with renter
households that have higher rates of cost burden receive proportionally
more funds than other counties.
And so the focus really is on what are called underserved communities
and how do we identify those underserved communities?
Well, the first step is we need to disaggregate the data.
So what does that mean?
That means that we look at their data by demographic information.
So we're looking at differences between income, race, gender,
language spoken.
We disaggregate it by geography and other relevant variables that
are relevant variables for your program efforts.
And I want to share an example of how equitable data practices
look like in action.
So I'm going to use the Digital Equity Act as an example.
So as part of the infrastructure bill, about $2.75 billion is
administered through our National Telecom and Information
Administration to communities that could benefit from digital skills
training, improved online accessibility, and really empowering
rural communities in particular to be able to measure and address
their own broadband needs.
So you may ask yourself, OK, where are those communities?
What type of population would benefit most from this?
So we know from research that these are the types of communities
that are less likely to have access to the Internet.
Folks that are making less than 150% of the poverty line.
Older folks, those who have been incarcerated, veterans, disabled,
those that face a language barrier, racial or ethnic minorities,
and those that tend to be in rural communities.
So then you may ask yourself, but where are they located?
So Census and NTIA collaborated to create the Digital Equity Act
population viewer.
And you can start to see here, at least on a state-by-state basis,
where are the states that have the most amount per capita of those
types of folks that are in those covered populations?
And when you dive a little bit deeper into this, say, for example,
in New Mexico, you can start to see the breakdown by that
disaggregation.
And you can also see here their usage as it comes to the Internet
and PC, also from ACS.
So ACS, I've been getting a tip or hats off in this session today.
And so, again, this is an example of how equitable data practitioners
start to better design programs so that way we are meeting the needs
of those who need it most.
And so I throw out this term, equitable data practitioner.
And we are in the business of illuminating opportunities
for targeted actions.
And as an equitable data practitioner, we are civic data entrepreneurs.
So we're inspiring new ways of thinking about data and analysis
in program design and delivery.
We are also change agents.
So we might not always have access to all the data we'd like to have,
but we look for the low-hanging fruit.
We see what we can do now.
We see coalitions of the willing.
Who's excited to do this work?
And then once we find really interesting, powerful ways to do
this work, we seek to institutionalize them.
So that way this just becomes how we do things.
And lastly, we are continuous learners.
So we're all learning together how to build the next-gen
government data infrastructure.
And it's really important that we look internally
across the federal landscape.
We look to state and local governments and nonprofits.
We look for the people who are benefiting from programs
and really engaging them in this continuous feedback loop.
So that is my call to you all.
Now that you have an idea of what equitable data practitioners do
and the stories that we can tell when we do our work well,
I invite you all to see yourselves as part of this movement.
And if you'd like to continue the conversation,
you can find me on LinkedIn.
So thank you very much, everyone.
And I pass the talking stick back to you.
Thank you, Shannon.
That was wonderful.
I really appreciate this.
So we're going to move to our last but not least speaker
who is Philip Deng.
He is co-founder and CEO of Grantable,
a world-class grant writing assistant for everyone
powered by AI.
Philip has been working at the nonprofit sector
for more than 15 years on three continents
and in three languages.
He loves to cook and gather with friends.
He lives in Richmond, Virginia with his partner Anita
and their two pups, Harper and Suki.
I love the personal touch, Philip.
Take it away.
Thank you so much, Aya.
And thank you, everybody, for having me at this summit.
It really is an honor that I feel like I've skipped
a few steps to arrive at.
But I'm grateful to be here.
And I don't have a presentation deck,
so I'm just going to try to speak and kind of bring my thoughts
together along with what the other presenters
have shared today.
Where I want to begin to set the stage is just to
call back to the bio that was just read about me.
I probably have the least amount of in-depth experience
with data and numbers of anybody on this panel.
My background is almost 15 years in the nonprofit sector
as a practitioner on the ground in different countries
working in different languages.
And my focus from that has been in grants.
And so I think I was asked to join today's panel to talk
about how data can be effective in storytelling
in a grants context.
And I think what are consistent themes with what everybody
else has shared today is that stories are very powerful.
There are problems that need to be solved.
And so we're asking ourselves today,
how can we measure the world around us to help us tell
these stories to solve problems?
And so I think grants are very much a synthesis of that effort.
For those of you that maybe don't know the statistics,
about $800 billion worth of funding is distributed
as grants every year.
My company's estimated probably about 30 million
grant proposals are written.
By all kinds of different organizations, agencies,
and even businesses as well.
We saw that during COVID for sure and people applying
for their different relief funds.
So that's sort of the context that I've been working in.
And one of the observations that I've made,
particularly in my role now transitioning from the
nonprofit sector into a tech startup role,
particularly one working with AI,
is that I believe the nature of data is changing
and so will storytelling with it.
As an example, probably many of you have heard of
or played around with chat GPT.
And for those of you who maybe haven't delved deeply into how
that chat bot is generating these wild and sometimes
very amazing skillful outputs,
it has been trained on a massive amount of data,
mostly text data from the internet and with enormous
amounts of computing power and complex algorithms.
It is teasing patterns out of that data and using probability
to generate these text outputs.
So I saw a parallel with today's theme and today's discussion
and I thought one of the things I could do for those gathered
here today is to kind of point out what I see happening
at scale here, which again is data is changing and the way
we can tell stories with it is as well.
So chat GPT is data and from it we are now coaxing out
patterns which are literally telling us stories.
If you go to this chat bot and you say,
hey, tell me a bedtime story, it will.
And it is doing that literally from massive amounts of data
which human engineers have trained to find patterns
and bring out of the data and it is now writing bedtime
stories if that is what you ask it to do.
So I just think one of the things that is very interesting
for I think the people gathered today is to stretch our
imaginations a little bit and think about what might
storytelling with numbers mean in the future, in the next few
months, in the next few years?
How are we going to take these themes of equity, these themes
of measuring impact and figuring out how to make
evidence-based decisions?
What else can we do if we lay a lens of this new paradigm
of tech-enabled data analysis to help us in that effort?
So that was one thing I really wanted to call out today
and ask people to think about and try.
And in that effort I will just say a lot of people I have
encouraged to do that, try it out and the first reaction
is a pretty heady mix of excitement and anxiety.
A lot of people are creeped out quite frankly by what these
things are capable of doing and what I'm not doing is
telling people to calm down or don't worry about it.
I'm actually telling everyone to listen to that emotion,
to that instinct that is saying, hey, this is different,
this is strange, this is unsettling, and to allow that
to heighten our senses and to say, okay, I'm now sitting up,
I'm paying attention, what is this thing and how do we all
collectively get our arms around it and use it?
So that's just one thing I wanted to mention that I think
is relevant in the moment as pertains to data.
And then to bring it back to grants, for those of you who
may be working on grants for different agencies or
organizations, some things I wanted to call out from my own
experience as a grant writer and recipient, I echo what
Brent said at the beginning to sort of begin with your
audience and to shape your narrative based on who are you
trying to tell a story to, who are you trying to move with
your narrative, and from there I think it usually becomes
clear what kind of data to use.
I also think based on your audience, you kind of have to
pick the Zoom that you're going to put on the numbers or the
quantitative material that you're using.
So if your funder, for example, is working on national level
initiatives, then you're probably going to want numbers
that convey the scale of work that is going to have a
national impact versus a local foundation.
This is, again, just in my purview, you would want
numbers that maybe actually highlight a clinic or a food
bank in the neighborhood where the funder lives and have
numbers that clarify that that's the level of focus that
you're trying to achieve.
So I think the scope is really important, as is choosing when
to use numbers and when to use words.
I think that's how I came into this conversation, but maybe
after hearing several of my co-panelists, I think it's kind
of how do you use both together in a really compelling way.
So I think the examples I came in with are when there's a
story of individual impact, you probably don't want to boil
that down to a single number or a few statistics.
But if you wanted to show change, if you wanted to show
how a program is growing and how prior grant funding has
impacted the ability to scale the benefits and impact, then
I think numbers are really powerful.
One of the last things I wanted to bring attention to is
unfortunately I would say when is measuring something or
measuring it in the wrong way?
When can data be harmful?
I don't think I heard that brought up, and I think it's a
very real outcome that unfortunately organizations can
find themselves in at times.
So what I've seen personally is organizations that are asked
to measure outcomes and program activities in a way that is
so detailed and burdensome that they either can't do it or
they're actually coming up with numbers that really, they
can't really stand behind.
In the worst cases, maybe made up, and in the best cases,
they're kind of fuzzy.
So I think that can be a real problem and I think something
that the field is starting to address.
I think also, I saw a comment earlier, if things get done
when we focus on them or whatever we measure tends to
get done.
I think that is usually meant as a positive, but in another
sense, sometimes if we measure something, everybody really
starts to try to make that metric rise or that metric fall,
whatever that metric starts to become this overwhelming force,
this guiding star, and I just think it's always important for
everybody to take a step back and look at what we're doing
because sometimes the pursuit of a single metric or a single
number can really be misleading for certain groups.
If you're just pursuing, say, profit, for example, I think
we're all looking at that and what the effects are on our
society.
That's obviously a very well-measured number in our
culture, but it doesn't quite capture all of the
externalities that sometimes pursuing just profits can
create for the society.
So I think that's an example that without singling anyone
out, I wanted to just throw that out there.
It can cause people to bend the truth.
It can cause people to draw the wrong conclusions.
So I think what I always advocate when I speak with
grantors and grantees that I coach, what can we do in terms
of data integrity and continuity?
So what I mean by that is what can we measure confidently,
accurately, and within our capacity and for the long term
so that we can see trends?
I think I see a lot of people sprint to try to win a grant
and they will devote lots of resources to game a number.
If we want lots of volunteers, if we have to show that we
have great participation numbers, then the entire
organization starts to shift all of its resources to
hosting events that are just big rather than effective.
So I think that's probably an example that a lot of folks
can relate to.
So hopefully some of that stuff brings at least some
questions to mind and I think I'm happy here to stand
alongside my more data expert co-panelists and if there's
anything about grant seeking and maybe particularly what's
happening with AI and technology.
I'm looking forward to some questions as well.
So hopefully I'm on time.
You are, Phil.
That was wonderful and we're not creeped out.
So thank you.
Thank you for talking about something that I think
everyone is wondering about and testing and I know many
folks in the media industry are wondering if they'll have
jobs in the next couple months as a result of this.
So I'm going to start the question period.
I'll start off with one question that was in the chat
from Kimi and it's for Philip.
Kimi says, I wonder if only the stories and data that are
being searched for will be identified by data gathering
and analysis.
What about the stories that are not identified?
Could you elaborate a little more?
I think there's a very, very interesting question that
I'd love to.
Okay.
So it's like a poll, right?
When poll takers go out, they have an assigned set of
questions and they're asking those questions, right?
And they get responses to them, right?
But sometimes the story, the items that are most
interesting to that community or most challenging to that
community don't correspond to the questions that are asked,
right?
So this is the same, you know, this could be similar, right?
So the people who are saying, you know, how do we evaluate
this data, right?
You know, maybe that data relates to a phenomenon that
hasn't emerged as being quantifiable or important yet.
Like the previous speaker, one of the previous speakers, she
said that an old man, 105-year-old man, he can't, like,
he can't live the same way he used to live.
He can't just be out in the community playing checkers and
what have you.
Like, the quality of his life has basically eroded because
of gentrification, right?
But this is not an expected outcome.
It's not something that someone who's not a community member
would think probably to look for.
So are we going to capture that data or not capture that data?
Okay.
Thank you for clarifying that.
I think my first reaction there is that what I believe is
increasingly possible is that we can take, let's take your
example of survey data and all those data points that are
coming in.
What I believe is increasingly possible is to apply more and
more computing power to data sets and what that power is
doing is looking for very, very complex patterns to emerge.
So I think what the frontier is and the work for us is I think
we're going to see connections that are both very, very
insightful, to use sort of what Brent brought up at first, and
I think we're going to see one of those connections that are
really challenging and reveal aspects of our society that are
extremely uncomfortable, maybe extremely controversial that
people are going to really have a lot of intense debate over.
So I think that maybe what you're saying, what are the other
things that are just beyond the questions that we're literally
asking people, I think more of that is going to be illuminated
by the basic computational advancements that companies are
making, and I think the role for all of us will be to prepare
for sort of, if you imagine literally light kind of filling
more of a darkness, we have to prepare as people to take on
what we see and what is revealed.
Thank you.
We appreciate that.
Thank you, Phillip.
I'm trying to keep track of some of the questions or statements.
It's mostly statements in the chat.
If anybody has a question, you can just speak up and ask any of
the panelists.
If nobody is speaking up, I see one question in the chat.
What do you do when officials want to apply one indicator
specific methodology to all related data requests because it
is easiest?
That sounds like a workplace issue, but I don't know if
Shannon or anyone else wants to address that.
I just wanted to clarify the conversation.
I feel like, hi, my name is Leah Icon.
I work at the Administration for Children's Services at New
York City, and I handle the child stat data analytics.
One thing that I find in terms of kind of, I created a unit
that kind of wanted to expand the data conversation to the
frontline staff as well as all the databases and the data
literacy behind all of these performance indicators and
metrics.
Sometimes it's hard to get people to really stop and use
the data.
Sometimes they be their minds a little bit to say, hey, these
are the questions asked of an indicator, and this is what the
answers are.
But over here for a city council report or something else,
there's a different question asked, but the words sound the
same.
And so I'm wondering because I really, really appreciated
Shannon's presentation today and speaking pretty much the same
kind of explain to my team of people how and why we do this is
to get out there, get the conversation from the community,
bring it back, and then kind of apply also the metric standards
to say, here's the basic ways we need to build a metric or an
indicator, but here's the questions that can be asked of it.
Here's the data behind it and full transparency.
But then there's another issue with, and I feel like it's not
just government.
It's a little bit bigger than this.
People not able to stop and think for just a second, like we
can ask different questions of indicators and let us quickly
storytell you the differences, right?
Like we try to bring in these like little stories or anecdotes
so that people will start to learn the difference between a
performance indicator asked of a frontline staff to speak to
versus what we might report at a citywide level.
And so I'm wondering if you have any guidance around how to stop
and slow people down that aren't really, that are too busy for
everything else, but you also need them to take notice that
these things are different.
Yeah, I'll share that I feel your pain.
I had a conversation today that had a very similar tone.
And the one thing that we know is that oftentimes these
indicators are a simplification of reality and that it really
needs to be contextualized.
And we're talking in the context of jobs, 50 jobs in an urban
region is not the same as 50 jobs in a tribal reservation.
And so context matters to situate these stats.
And so just balancing the case studies with the indicators and
coupling them together, we found to be helpful moving forward.
But I'll pass the talking stick back.
And I see what you're struggling with for sure.
I hope that answered your question.
I see a question in the chat for Lam.
Where would you go to build a story about how federal dollars
are spent by agency for a specific geographic area like
Puerto Rico?
Oh, okay.
Puerto Rico is probably different.
There are databases that look into contracts.
I think there's a lot of relationships between government
agencies and private contractors and what that expenditure looks
like.
If you ping me afterwards, I can find you the exact source that
we used for something similar.
I do not know whether that specific database I have in mind
also looks to Puerto Rico, but I can look into that.
And because I'm also part of the investigative reporters and
editors network, I can ask a few folks who are working there to
stay in touch.
And then the other thing that you might want to think about is
the way in which I teach data is oftentimes the data sets that
are being given out to the public are not always everything
that an agency has.
And so this might be a longer term kind of project or a longer
term endeavor, but a lot of the times thinking about the forms
that people fill out or the databases that governments use
and then figuring out a way of filing Freedom of Information Act
requests or public records requests might be a way for you
to play around with finding data sets around the subject you
care about.
And the last but not least, as a practitioner of data collection
and I'm a coder, I do a lot of Python scraping, there are also
ways to investigate these types of subjects with data sets that
are adjacent to that, whether it's through public databases
that like private databases like Property Shark or something
like that, for example, or databases that you kind of build
yourself.
I call them DIY data sets, do it yourself data sets by cobbling
together information that lives on the Internet and then putting
that into a spreadsheet and then analyzing it for that.
That might be an interesting way for you to look into that.
That's great, Lam.
It looks like we've come to the end of our session.
So anybody who has questions, I think you can reach out
directly to all of our panelists.
Their contact information is in the chat and I believe that this
will be made available to everyone.
So again, thank you.
Round of applause to everyone who spoke today was fascinating.
Thank you again.
Thank you.
And before we wrap up real quick, I just want to mention a
quick comment.
I heard something I was kind of I stepped away for a second
around contracts in Puerto Rico and data.
I'm going to drop two links in the chat that you might be
interested in.
This organization that is doing great work and working with
Open Contracting Partnership, which is an offshoot of the
World Bank.
And you heard from one of those speakers earlier in Top Summit.
So check those two links out.
It's contracts in law and it's great being more than 58
government websites in Puerto Rico and then basically mapping
out every contract, every RFP, NOFO and procurement transaction
to open corporates data and business register data in
Puerto Rico.
So check that out.
It's on the chat.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Bye, everyone.
Thank you for moderating, show speakers, Brent, Lam, Phillip
and Shannon.
It was a pleasure to have you guys.
I learned so much.
Thank you all for participating in Top Summit 2023.
Thank you.